earth has gone through at least five
major ice ages in its history
and you better start adapting now
because another ice age is about to
begin
hypothetically
how would a new ice age change earth as
we know it
what could you do to survive on a frozen
planet
and how are we already delaying another
ice age
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we entered a new ice age
during all ice ages in earth's history
global temperatures dropped well below
freezing across the planet
and it wasn't just a few icy trips
around the sun earth can take hundreds
of millions of years to thaw out
the most recent ice age started the
quaternary period around 2.6 million
years ago and technically we're still in
it today
ice ages have the power to radically
change our planet
they reshape landscapes they create new
lakes and rivers
plants and animals cling to life either
adapting or facing extinction
so
if a new ice age began today
how soon would our civilization collapse
into chile chaos
our sixth major ice age would be a few
thousand years in the making
and it would begin with earth's tilt on
its axis going through its cycle of
changes
an unstable tilt plus a little wobble in
our orbit around the sun and there would
be less and less solar radiation
reaching the planet
you'd see the first effects of this on
the northern hemisphere
each year the once lovely summer
temperatures would start to drop
eventually they'd fail to rise above
freezing
and that's when the snowfall would begin
to build up
over time that snow would compress into
ice sheets
these glaciers would start in places
like the northernmost regions of canada
scandinavia and russia and they would
spread from there
the ice would mostly form on dry land
that's because the waters surrounding
the ice would create a barrier
preventing it from expanding as easily
today about 10 percent of earth's land
surface is covered by ice
as our new ice age progresses you could
see that go up to about 25 percent
ice would cover eurasia from the british
isles to siberia
himalayan ice sheets would expand
through asia and while the southern
hemisphere wouldn't be as icy an ice
sheet would run from the southern tip of
patagonia well into the andes mountains
but ice wouldn't be the only change
sea levels could drop around 120 meters
lower than they are right now
this could close off the mediterranean
sea to the atlantic ocean
without anywhere else to go
rainfall and glacial melting would feed
bodies of water in regions that aren't
frozen over
some rivers would also change their
usual runoffs and form new lakes
with all these changes in sea levels
around the world
land bridges would re-emerge
russia would now be connected to alaska
and the islands of indonesia would
connect to mainland southeast asia
the borders would change and bring many
countries closer together
or it would result in whole new
countries being formed opening up new
land for you to migrate to
and you'd need to
regions that you and hundreds of
millions of other people used to call
home would be
essentially uninhabitable
surviving the cold would mean moving
away from the iciest parts of north
america and eurasia
but the rest of the world wouldn't be
too welcoming either
it would get really dry
deserts and tundras would expand so the
remaining tropical forests near the
equator would be refuge for much of the
planet's plant and animal life
but what about us
well during the most recent ice age we
actually developed as a species
the land bridges allowed us to spread
out across the globe and the climate
forced us to adapt with new tools and
clothing
and as earth rewarmed we started farming
it's likely that we wouldn't fare as
well with a new ice age
not right away at least
almost all of our agricultural land
would be lost
so intense overcrowding in hospitable
regions would create chaos and unrest
you should get ready for extreme
competition for life's basic necessities
but i do have good news to ease your
worries about this frigid doomsday
scenario
come on
sort of
based on current climate science and the
amount of carbon dioxide in our
atmosphere we may have postponed the
next possible ice age by about half a
million years
and if we keep pumping out greenhouse
gases
it's possible that we've not only
postponed it but we've made it
impossible
that just means we'll all
overheat which i guess is better than
being frozen
so earth freezing over may not need to
be high on your worry list but
maybe all the world's ice melting should
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]